ne se parlent plus on se dit même plus
bonjour
jeunes diplômés on a un fort
ressentiment l'un pour l'autre en tout
cas moi j'en ai un je pense qu'il est
partagée c'est depuis la polémique de
l'année dernière sur raciste homophobe
etc j'ai totalement coupé les ponts avec
mathieu je ne lui parle plus je lui dis
plus bonjour espère que tu ouvriras le
rideau ça fait des mois qu'on ne se
parle plus je pense que le moment est
venu de se reparler de tir et ça aucun
envie de touvre le rideau pour venir
vers toi si jamais tu l'ouvrés de serrer
la main et te dire repartons sur de
bonnes bases redevenons amis je suis
d'ordinaire pas rancunier mais là je
n'ouvre pas de rideaux tous les cas pas
maintenant parce que j'attendais de
gilles c'est vrai depuis six mois à
défaut d'excusés au moins des regrets
rien est arrivé or il s'est très bien la
raison de notre brouille allait quand
même très violente et donc
je n'ai jamais compris que pendant six
mois il n'est jamais eu la délicatesse
au moins si le fasse pas l'antenne
peut-être dans les coulisses de venir
s'excuser ou encore une fois j'ai dit